[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 29 novembre 2016
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres à
peine être désigné françois fillon fait
face à une première série de division
contestation violente d'henri guaino
député des yvelines pour qui ce
programme va détruire la cohésion de la
nation et contestation aussi d'une
partie des jeunes de l'udps et i qui
viennent de se ranger derrière emmanuel
macron présidentielle toujours et lutte
ouvrière en campagne nathalie arthaud
était dans les yvelines pour défendre
sans relâche les travailleurs et puis à
quelques jours de l'ouverture du salon
de la littérature jeunesse nous irons à
la rencontre de la maison d'édition rue
du monde une maison d'édition implantée
à voisins le bretonneux et qui
participera pour la vingtième année à ce
rendez vous ait les suites de la
primaire de la droite et du centre avec
la publication hier d'une tribune signée
par quelques 230 militants de lui des
jeunes de 130 militants qui ont pris la
décision de s'engager aux côtés d'
emmanuel macron une décision motivée par
la désignation de françois fillon
dimanche soir dont il critique le
programme le président national de
l'udps ayez jeunes évoquent des
initiatives uniquement personnel il
relativise écouter marc lerouge chez le
président de la fédération udi jeunes
des yvelines
il ya eu des réactions très excessive
très excessive à cette tribune certains
nous expliquant que nous avions décidé
de quitter mini moi personnellement je
n'ai pas décidé de tout mini fût très à
l'aise dans ma famille politique
aujourd'hui les idées formulées par
rentrer fillon il leur a il a répété
encore ce matin à dire qu' il ne
bougerait pas sur ce programme c'est ce
qu'il a dit et j'ai même envie de dire
il a raison il a raison il a été élu
pour faire un programme donc il a
entièrement raison maintenant nous par
rapport aux idées sur l'europe
aujourd'hui françois fillon était
absolument inaudible c'est un sujet qui
nous intéresse pas sur l'écologie ça ne
l'intéresse pas sur les questions
sociétales ça l'intéresse mais alors ça
va pas du tout dans le sens où nous
voulons aller et aujourd'hui emmanuel
mac os x les propositions simplement
c'est que quand il a quitté le
gouvernement udi et président dudit a
dit que j'en avais occasion a parlé avec
gros qu'il était de centre gauche que
nous étions du centre-droit que nous
allions vocation avait parlé et à faire
bouger les lignes politiquement une
autre contestation celle d'henri guaino
le député des yvelines ancien conseiller
de nicolas sarkozy a livré ce matin une
charge musclée contre le candidat de la
droite et du centre c'était sur
l'antenne de bfm tv de rmc henri guaino
a accusé françois fillon de vouloir
détruire la solidarité nationale et la
cohésion de la nation il a également
estimé que son programme faisait le jeu
du front national en jeu site tapant
aveuglément sur les fonctionnaires l'élu
a enfin réaffirmé qu'il poursuivait son
ambition de se présenter lui aussi à la
présidentielle et pendant ce temps là
elle poursuit la campagne elle c'est
nathalie arthaud de lutte ouvrière en
déplacement à mantes la jolie ce week
end elle a réaffirmé que les
travailleurs devaient prendre le pouvoir
par la révolution le reportage d'anne
laure langues et sur des images libres
une première
c'est une salle comble et attentive qui
a accueilli samedi dernier à
mantes-la-jolie la candidate de lutte
ouvrière nathalie arthaud s'était déjà
présenté en 2012 dans son discours ce
week end elle a rappelé l'importance du
combat des travailleurs une voie qu'elle
estime être la seule à porter pour 2017
quand vous écoutez la télévision ou la
radio les seuls candidats que l'on
entend à c'est la droite c'est le parti
socialiste ces macro tous ces gens là
ils sont unanimes unanimes pour dire que
les travailleurs ils ont trop de droits
que les travailleurs sont trop bien
protégées
l'industrie fait partie de l'adn des
yvelines second bassin d'emploi après la
défense l'actualité récente a fourni au
soutien de nathalie arthaud des
arguments pour sa campagne dans un
groupe hyper riches renault il ya un
plan de compétitivité
où les patrons voudrait faire faire aux
travailleurs des heures supplémentaires
gratuites samedi etc et pendant ce temps
là il ya 6 millions de chômeurs du côté
des autres militants rassemblés à mantes
la jolie l'enthousiasmé ne fléchit pas
pour la candidate qui n'a rassemblé que
0 56% des voix en 2012 dans la droite
continuité d'un raid laguiller dont elle
fut la porte parole nathalie arthaud
incarne les idées de son parti
ce n'est pas par les urnes que ça
changera les choses ce n'est pas en
en élisant un candidat qui prendra place
au pouvoir que les choses changent on
s'est parlé lutte les luttes sociales
qui ont fait bouger les choses c'est à
dire c'est quoi il faut pas miser sur le
cheval gagnant pour miser sur celui
qu'on veut et le nathalie c'est pas un
cheval c'est des idées qu'elle véhicule
et c'est pour ça qu'on vote c'est pas
pour une personne après ce passage dans
les yvelines nathalie arthaud partira
dès janvier pour une série de meetings à
travers toute la france objectif
réveiller les travailleurs comme elle se
plaît à le dire
parlons à présent d'une initiative
originale le réseau fébus vélizy a
décidé de parfumer ces bus pour les
rendre plus agréable depuis le 1er
novembre vous l'avez peut-être remarqué
si vous utilisez ces différentes lignes
une senteurs fraîches embaume les
véhicules anne laure longue et mickaël
millero usagers des bus entre versailles
et vélizy voilà qui pourrait améliorer
votre quotidien
le 1er novembre dernier 80 véhicules du
réseau ont été dotés d'un vaporisateur
de parfums à chaque fois que les portes
s'ouvrent et se referment
celui ci entre en action nous avons
effectivement l'objectif que rendre plus
agréable le transport entre vélizy et
versailles sur l'ensemble du réseau de
vélizy afin que nos voyageurs puissent
passer du temps dans une ambiance
serra sera n est aimable c'est une
initiative des conducteurs de bus elle
répond aussi aux nouveaux critères du
grand paris visant à rendre les
transports en commun plus confortable
les usagers quant à eux sont ravis pour
le bus tous les jours et c'est vrai que
ça fait du bien de me faire autre chose
que le dos
mais au fait de quel parfum s'agit-il
baptisé lagon le produit diffuse des
senteurs marines pour créer un sentiment
d'évasion revendique la société
gestionnaire du réseau pas sûr que tout
le monde s'y retrouve
on pas trop je vois pas du tout à quoi
savoir bon c'est arrivé que c'était
boisé
enfin où fleurit d odeur florale encore
à connais pas ce que c'est exactement ça
veut plus penser à la mer où nous
redresse à la mer enfin une bonne
réponse si l'expérience est approuvée
par une majorité d'usagers
ce sont d'autres lignes des réseaux de
vélizy et de saint cyr qui seront
équipés un tout autre sujet à présent le
soutien scolaire est aujourd'hui devenu
un marché à part entière avec de
nombreuses sociétés qui se sont lancés
elle prospère est néanmoins les communes
assurent toujours cette activité
essentielle pour les familles exemple à
montigny le bretonneux avec un nicolas
kirillovitch c'est patrick jacques de
dixmude
mathématiques français géographie ou
langue étrangère faire ses devoirs avant
de rentrer à la maison c'est l'objectif
des études surveillées à montigny le
bretonneux ce dispositif existe depuis
2003 et emploie plus d'une trentaine de
vacataires pour surveiller les enfants
trois fois par semaine entre 17 et 18
heures ils sont là pour assurer
effectivement la surveillance de l'étude
pendant l'heure ils sont responsables
des élèves et ils doivent s'assurer que
les élèves fasse bien leurs devoirs
pendant sept heures voilà donc c'est de
l'accompagnement scolaire mais c'est pas
de lait de voir la différence donc entre
aide aux devoirs et études surveillées
la réalité elle est plus complexe
difficile de ne pas répondre à des
élèves en difficulté je vois pas la
possibilité qu'il y en a un qui me
demande est ce que tu peux m'aider
pauline et je peux pas lui répondre non
moi je suis là pour surveiller jeu je
sais que je peux l'aider alors je me
fais après la boisson qui font de
l'allemand je pourrai pas les ai déjà
mais finalement donc là j'essaie d'entre
eux c'est bien mais les plus petits pour
la lecture je le fais toujours avec eux
la dictée mots je le fais aussi avec eux
chaque semaine 900 élèves profit des
études surveillées à montigny le
bretonneux un accompagnement utile pour
les parents et qui plaît aux enfants
j'aime bien puisque tu fais tes devoirs
et après tu as pas faire de cette foire
à ta maison et tu peux jouer parce que
j'aime c'est rester avec mes copains fin
mai devoir tranquille et lire des livres
mois pour faire mes devoirs quand je
suis tout seul chez moi va je trouve que
c'est plus difficile pour réaliser que
quand je suis avec mes amis on aurait
donc je préfère être à véhicule que tout
seul chez moi fort de son succès le
dispositif des études surveillées est
proposée sur l'ensemble des 15 écoles
élémentaires de montigny le bretonneux
rue du monde la maison d'édition vie
sinoise fête ses 20 ans et elle se
prépare à une nouvelle participation
pour une nouvelle fois au salon du livre
de la jeunesse qui se tient du 30
novembre au 5 décembre à montreuil
comment le créateur a réussi à faire
perdurer cette aventure nous sommes
allés à lui poser la question mélanie
poker
300 livres 6 jours et dix personnes
mobilisées le salon du livre de la
jeunesse de montreuil est le rendez vous
annuel pour rue du monde la maison
d'édition vicinaux asie sera pour la
vingtième année consécutive
c'est la principale manifestation
en europe autour de la littérature
jeunesse et aux nous y participons
depuis le premier salon de 1996 où nous
avons débarqué sur un petit temps de 1 m
de large avec un livre le grand livre
des droits de l'enfant illustré par pef
les médias parlent très peu du livre
jeunesse
un très très peu
je crois qu'il n'a pas perçu en france
qu'il y avait un livre jeunesse
extrêmement brillant qui fait justement
briller les yeux du monde entier tous
les professionnels du livre et de
l'enfance il se crée ici des livres
extraordinaires beaucoup douze mille
nouveaux titres par an nous on n'en fait
qu'une trentaine à là dedans
ce sont les originaux des derniers
livres que nous publions bonnes
nouvelles du monde et donc nathalie novi
grande illustratrice nous a confié ses
images qu'elle a réalisée à la suite
bien sûr de la lecture du texte en 20
ans rue du monde a édité plus de 400
titres la maison est né d'un financement
participatif un crowfunding avant
l'heure maintenant un gros chantier
beaucoup de travail 425 livres le
réaliser depuis ce jour où j'ai de 1996
où j'ai un peu
follement décidé de créer une maison
d'édition alors que j'étais auteur de
livres jeunesse j'avais publié une
cinquantaine de livres dans de
nombreuses maisons d'édition
invitation au voyage découverte des
enfants du monde entier rue du monde
amène à réfléchir aux droits des plus
jeunes chaque année la maison offre 5000
livres au secours populaire français un
engagement qui sera partagé lors des
cinq jours du salon de montreuil
salon du livre de jeunesse de montreuil
qui débute donc dès demain un portrait à
présent elle a été élue jeune femme
scientifique de l'année nathalie
carrasco chercheuse à lui vs qu a reçu
le prix irène joliot curie pour ses
recherches sur l'atmosphère de titan
c'est l'un des satellites de saturne
nous l'avons rencontrée
tenter de comprendre l'origine de la vie
sur terre nathalie carrasco en a fait
son métier sa spécialité l'atmosphère de
titan le plus gros satellite de saturne
facture on a plein de lune différentes
mais il y en a une seule titans qui a
une atmosphère très épaisse une
atmosphère fait date et donc ne prospère
qui ressemble à celle de la terre passé
de la terre avant l'émergence de la vie
depuis 2005 avec le début de la mission
cassini elle étudie la chimie de
l'atmosphère de titan sa composition
unique dans le système solaire se
rapproche celle de la terre il ya 4
milliards d'années ces atomes là le
carbone et la zot sont vraiment à
l'origine de la chimie primitive des
acides aminés des des sucres c'est
vraiment des composés important par
rapport à la formation de précurseur de
la vie donc ya pas de vis sur titan mais
en étudiant fait chimie on apporte une
compréhension de comment la chimie de
l'atmosphère a pu conduire à la
formation de briques de la vie pour
accompagner l'émergence du vivant sur la
terre primitive pour ces travaux
nathalie carrasco est devenu jeune femme
scientifique de l'année 2016 en
septembre elle a reçu le prix irène
joliot curie c'est une grande fierté ce
prix est pour moi vraiment le symbolise
à la fois à titre individuel ma
recherche est vraiment très très fier
d'avoir reçu ce prix en plus gelé reçu
de la main de madame hélène
langevin-joliot donc la fille irène
joliot curie donc une grande fierté mais
également je suis très fier parce pour
le symbole que cela représente à savoir
le fait que les femmes ont toute leur
place dans la recherche scientifique la
mission cassini de se terminer en 2017
mais avec les données collectées
nathalie carrasco continuera ses
recherches titan n'a pas fini de
dévoiler tous ses secrets
fin du journal en dévot demain aux
horaires habituels pour une nouvelle
édition tous les replays sur sur notre
site internet en attendant les
programmes se poursuivre sur téléphiles
bonne soirée
[Musique]